ORDER THEM SECTOR KALRA PLEASE.
KALRA HERE FLORA. THE END.
GONZALEZ. JONES SAWYER RESULT.
THREE OF US. THANK YOU SIR
REALLY MON WE HAVE A BACK ON A.
B. AB THREE SEVEN IS BACK WITH
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS FOR
CONCURRENCE OF PLEASE. THANK
YOU TURN MEMBERS. I HAVE SOME
FOLKS HERE AND I IN SUPPORT OF
THE. REALLY RESONATED WITH
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION HERE FOR TECHNICAL
MOMENTS AND- OBVIOUSLY AND I
BOTH. BRIAN NELSON ON BEHALF OF
THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
STATE COUNTY MUNICIPAL
EMPLOYEES WITH RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST NOT VOTE THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
AFTERNOON BEVERLY YOU WITH UT
W. ASKED ME LOCAL THREE NINE
THIRTY CO SPONSORS PRESS ONE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION. RIGHT WELL WE HAVE
A MOTION ANY OTHER COMMENTS
FROM. MEMBERS IF NOT SOONER THE
LAW JUDGE CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND SECTORS COAL
THANK YOU. MOTION IS RECOMMEND
THAT SENATE AMENDMENTS BE
CONCURRED IN KALRA HI. KALRA HI
FLORA FLORA I AGREE OKAY. NO
IDEA GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I JONES
SAWYER HI JONES OR I
THREE OF US THREE OF US I. ALL
RIGHT THOSE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT IN AND WE'RE GOING
TO IMMEDIATELY TRANSMIT THIS
TOO FOR. A QUICK. NOT YET ALL
RIGHT SO WE CAN TAKE. UP A SAP
THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. YEP OKAY
BY THE AT NIGHT HERE